النجم محمد رمضان من يوم ما قال انا نمبر
وان والجدل حول الموضوع هذا ولكن هذا
الشيء عمره ما منعوا انه يستمر في تلقيب
نفسه بهذا اللقب والتاكيد على الموضوع
كمان واليوم عنده حلقه جديده من حلقات
التاكيد على ان الرقم واحد فبالتزامن مع
النجاح الساحق لمسلسل الرمضاني جعفر
العمده نشر محمد رمضان على حساباته خبر
انه هو اول فنان عربي هاشتاج اسمه يوصل 9
مليار مشاهده على تيك توك اللافت في بوست
محمد رمضان مو بس اعلان عن الانجاز لكن
كلامه اللي قال فيه لو سالوني تختار مين
غيرك اول نجم عربي يوصل للرقم ده ويستحق
لاني بحبه من صغري وبحترم مشواره ومجهود
وفحقول عن جداره محمد رمضان اللي هو انا
برضو فعموما احنا فتحنا تيك توك نتاكد من
هاشتاق محمد رمضان ولقينا انه فعلا هاشتاج
اسمه عليه اكثر من 9 ملايين او تسعه مليار
مشاهده ومنه طبعا للاعلى محمد والنجاح
للنجاح اكيد
[موسيقى]